today three out of the four largest
financial institutions are nearly 80
percent bigger then before we bail them
out because they were too big to fail
well sort of within bailout all the big
banks but the biggest US banks are just
as big if not bigger than they were
before the crisis in 2008 JPMorgan Chase
is 75 percent bigger than it was in 2006
Bank of America 50 percent Wells Fargo
four times bigger only Morgan Stanley
and Citigroup
are slightly smaller than they were
during the height of the crisis the
relatively healthier banks ended up
buying the failing banks as a way of
rescue and these rescues were back in
some cases by the government you can
deal with these adjustments insulate
Main Street from Wall Street JP Morgan
bought Washington Mutual and Bear
Stearns Bank of America got countrywide
and Merrill Lynch Wells Fargo part of a
cobia a rival that was actually bigger
in size we've had hundreds of rules and
regulations in the US and around the
world to make sure that the taxpayer is
not on the hook next time around capital
at the biggest five banks on average is
six percent which is twice as much as it
was before the crisis but it's still
miniscule compared to startups within
one year my administration will break
these institutions are eight years after
the fall of Lehman Brothers too big to
fail is clearly still alive we need to
repeal and replace dodd-frank what we
ought to do is raise the capital
requirements so banks aren't too big
there are plenty of opinions as to why
and how to deal with it but one thing is
for sure
risk in the financial system
is still unknown and can suddenly pop up
nobody can be sure that the dominoes
won't start falling again like they did
in 2008 and with the banks even bigger
now the American taxpayer may be asked
once again to pick up the pieces